back here on the show now to promote his
new program that's been on since the 1st
of March on Fox mental Samurai
Tuesdays at 9:00 Eastern Time produced
and hosted by this man Rob yes - sir I'm
good as what savvy you know I finally on
Instagram and that's the way people you
know people know hey I heard you had a
trip to Italy and you you muted me
because I yeah half the time I seen your
hand I'm getting serious about my golf
game yet my kids are out of the house
okay so I've got the time I took 20
years off from the game when my kids
were young right yeah I literally did
not swing a club right which is great
because I got to really relearn the
swing mm-hmm and it's been awesome
you're locked in now why don't I bet
that it's golf yeah how locked in can I
be I'm not playing it I'm locked in on
playing and I want to play the AT&T
you're in the right spot for that
because you think you know the dirty
little secret about any celebrity golf
thing okay all you need is two great
shots and you're on ESPN dinah dinah not
and nobody cares if you shot a hundred
right right you're gonna get on if you
had a great shot if your celebrity I
write I thought I did you're exactly
right and the par threes are where you
can really make your Hey that's all I
need to do is just have a great swing at
the par-3 just try and throw a dart at
the stick and all of a sudden you look
like you're a two-handed where's the
good news my swing looks like I could
play in the Masters the problem is where
the ball goes
that's the issue does that mean because
I'm an actor so I can fake anything I
can fake do something like if because an
actor you learn so many things you know
play a cowboy you play a doctor you like
you play a dot like I played a doctor
like if you if anybody in the studio had
a medical emergency right now god forbid
I could almost help but what we would
still flatline you find at the end of
the day but you'd look damn good there
are three is if they just yeah keep that
angle on the swing right dude I'm loving
life which role in the in the history of
your career Rob did you have to learn
the most for that you actually had to
really stick the landing
Oh honestly probably code black where
I'm playing the military
trauma doctor hmm there's there's so
much prop work and dense and stints and
bandages right
crazy medical jargon yeah yeah like you
do a show like Annie to a hospital show
yes and you feel like you could save
somebody's life but you can't so it
wasn't Tommy Boy what did I learn for
Tommy Boy what did you were a great
Caesar haircut her spade calls me Lee
Harvey Oswald is my favorite ad-lib he
he calls my character Lee Harvey Oswald
because of the hair pretty funny well
you look pretty damn natural hosting
mental samurai sir this is this is
pretty wild it's like so I'm a huge fan
of American Ninja Warrior my kids cannot
stop watch best show ever so it's it's
the same people that created that and
they came to me and we're like alright
warriors for the physical yeah how do we
build an obstacle course for the mind
mm-hmm and I was like that's great cuz I
love trivia I'm really good I'm brutal
Trivial Pursuit I will whip your butt
see now I would take the challenge on
that but the green the green science you
know that's edge always well it was the
conundrum for me sir
everybody has their weakness yes and so
we designed this course a to be an
obstacle course as a physical component
you got to get through you didn't yet
not just standing at a podium hitting a
buzz or any idiot can do that yes so
it's it's a it's a full experience but
if you have a weakness like that -
puzzles puzzles puzzles yeah like Sudoku
kind of all things and stuff like that
yeah I'm it's not I'm not good there's
certainly if you're being whizzed around
in some sort of semicircular that arm
that arm is a four and a half million
dollar piece of equipment and it has
multiple settings we have seven people
standing by to make sure that the
settings are appropriate because you we
think killing the contestants would be
bad radius it's bad for business we
think it is I think it's a wise yeah so
wise policy we think it is it is a wise
part were you ever a game show guy I was
on the $10,000 pyramid when I was
fifteen by the way it's hilarious that
$10,000 is unimaginable money I you
can't fly to New York first class for
Tempah
the show well I'm about to do the
$100,000 period we're going to yawn I am
it's me versus Joel McHale on stray
hands we're taping at frog summer I was
I was just against Tony Danza you versus
me against Danza now did you give away
money did you win I went to the pyramid
every time and I won the pyramid I'm
straight you did Rob Lowe yeah that's
pretty cool you left Dan's in your dust
I loved Danza I mean oh yeah he's a
boxer and he was knocked out I cannot
wait to do this like lizard I live I
live for you okay and I mean this don't
let your mind go in the gutter are you a
better giver or a better taker well you
know what I'm a giver I'm again I put
when it comes to when it comes to when
it comes to game shows yes you've got a
big heart you know you know pretty much
you know I I it was yeah but some people
you know could go you know either way
you I I hate when they give you the uh
you like just give me the clue
you mean that clue there's a technique
to all of us well I imagine in your
current show there's a lot of stuttering
like that - because I just knowing just
knowing just knowing just doing stuff
that you don't normally do is
out-of-body but I can only imagine
sitting in the castle seat in the car
and there's Rob Lowe giving you quizzes
I mean it's gonna be really strange when
the clock is ticking we had a guy the
other day who was so discombobulated by
the the centrifugal forces that his
question was named this white Sol
best-selling pop duo from the 80s and
there was a picture of a hall way and a
bowl of oats and he literally was like
okay so I see Hall and I see oats I see
a hallway if I both cereal oats and I'm
dying for him but it just goes to show
you when you when you're moved out of
your comfort zone hard to get haulin
oats baby even when you're looking at
Hall and Oates
what'd he say Wham did he never got him
he never got it never got of him yeah I
mean just that's some of the most epic
you know show fails like in Wheel of
Fortune where everything's revealed
except one syllable that's all and one
letter feels it are my guilty pleasure
right there's a host you can't have that
like I know what's really funny what I
didn't wasn't prepared for is how much
as a host you invest in these people and
how much you want them to win sure and
you become just a fan oh and a coach but
you can't coach him because there's a
lot of rules and you're all very managed
just know so I have to really sit on my
natural inclination which is to go Paula
notes right man that's a mate I mean I I
think it's great that the American ninja
warriors people come up to you and say
let's do this sort of thing cool cuz
that it just looks amazing it's just a
lot of fun and I'm glad you're having
fun yeah it's really really cool so do
you have you have questions over there
Chris do you have that yeah so I googled
Trivial Pursuit questions and these are
real ones from the game what category
and I love don't screw me all categories
alright I'll start with a sports
question if you guys would like are you
fine with that I'm so competitive I
always want to play okay okay let's go
you know I might get killed the host of
mental samurai I feel like I don't judge
my show based on my answers I will say
which football coach of Notre Dame was
joe Montana's roommate at Notre Dame
which football coach of Notre Dame was
joe Montana's roommate at Notre Dame oh
boy that's a that's um so I'm gonna say
it's what we know it wasn't Lou Holtz
its it was at I Willingham Charlie Weis
serious but Charlie Weis was his
roommate at Notre Dame what what does it
seem right somehow so before there was
Montana to rice there was Montana to
rice with a bong in the room Oh Charlie
yeah this is before the the surgery so
I'm sure Prince pre-surgery pre-surgery
here's one yeah who was ross perot's
running mate in the 92 presidential
electors right yeah well done see now
you're my wheelhouse what scatter
was that that was how to be politics
right history I'm just looking at
history that by the way have you ever
gotten a Trivial Pursuit question where
you were the answer happen in a game I
have had it yeah it's kind of fun
that's just I've been watching jeopardy
and I've been an answer no kid that's a
good right there Times crossword puzzle
financier have you know I don't know if
you saw in the Rich Eisen show greenroom
but there it is
you've arrived I know I don't put in the
bathroom put their Oscars dude yes I did
not absolutely know that because it
shows you don't care don't you know
that's oh I could see do you got one
more over there one more one more
okay which international pop sensation
was the drummer for the band Breakfast
Club before she broke out as a solo star
geez oh boy I got me current people and
anything with her with Breakfast Club
you think I'd know think you'd know it's
kinda in your wheelhouse
I mean the John Hughes never gave me a
job he never did did never gave me a job
I audition for The Breakfast Club didn't
get it which which role did you audition
for in the front Judd Nelson its role
you'd have been fit on the bad the bad
guy but bad wasn't taking what I was
selling what's what gives with that I
don't know did you ever get a chance to
ask it never did because I mean the guy
did 500 movies I could have been in what
Madonna wait wait a minute wait a minute
was a sidekick you mean to tell me
Madonna was in a group called The
Breakfast Club as the drums Dan Gilroy
was Madonna's boyfriend for a while and
let her sing lead vocals in his band for
a short time yeah I'm gonna by the way
I'm gonna rescind that I could beat you
in Trivial Pursuit I kind of whipped on
almost all of them we didn't look we
didn't do that was not a good show no
for us no the fact that you just blurted
out Admiral Stockdale was very it was
great I do remember it was he was he
caught he could hardly put two words
together that's right you know I do
remember that well he said why am I here
and the debate is that right why am I
here we're like well you don't know
don't look at us one more
by the way an American Hero doctor just
said oh no I know that yeah pop culture
some say the logo looks like Don Draper
in the history of Mad Men
how many secretaries did Don Draper
employ ooh I'll go I'll go with three
I'm gonna go with one nine yes often
secretaries on Mad Men bad no it doesn't
I think we look like one who's hosting a
show other than this one I'm whole thank
God I'm not competing it we clearly we
got easier questions celebrity
true/false with Rob Lowe go ahead over
there Mike Delta fo true even a tree
[Music]
the sting of Spandau Ballet gets us into
this I always loved that okay we have
some we have some questions from your
history whether it's true or false all
right okay here we go for this is my own
history I think I should know this on
the Internet we have no idea if it's
true or false true or false one of your
celebrity or false with Rob Lowe again
mental samurai on Fox Tuesdays at 9:00
Eastern Time one of your first on-screen
credits is an after-school special
school boy father about teenage
pregnancy true or false with a title
like that how could it be anything other
titles about those things were great it
was always like telling you exactly what
it what it was my peanut allergy will
kill me tomorrow three well actually I
should know the answer this because I
read I read one of your books and you
didn't you tell a story I do why do you
know one by the way I do a one-man show
which you have to come to instead of
writing a third book yes I created this
one-man show I'm playing with Vegas on
the 13th wait a second wait I'm playing
the scene
wait which casino which Planet Hollywood
I'm in the course I mean god it's so fun
that I fly it's like a dream come true
for me
so you're but I did I do a big
after-school special riff in it which
what made me think of okay that's
fantastic
it's so cool so if you're a guy
anybody's around Vegas on the 13th okay
it's my Vegas debut now you tell the see
Elvis is this story about
Cary Grant right I tell it's in the show
can you can you recount that right now
real quick there's two of them okay the
one with the soap on the rope yeah
that's the one that's the one that's in
so very first time I ever mmm watched
myself star and anything was the
after-school special school boy farm and
I was trying to date his daughter who is
this Court is still is gorgeous Jennifer
and she said come to my house you'll
watch it with my dad my dad's an actor I
didn't put two and two together Cary
Grant answered the door had no idea that
Jennifer grant was Cary Grant's daughter
and I watched Schoolboy father with Cary
Grant and he was like you remind me of a
young Warren Beatty and how they call
that's great and then as I left because
he was like a brand ambassador for Fabri
Shea there you are in the in the film
right it looks like I'm starring in the
Karen Carpenter's
by the way your young man I really don't
understand that might be the most
sexually ambiguous am I actually
breastfeeding I need to see that he I
could actually be breastfeeding
photograph but as a masculine young man
watching this with Cary Grant and as I
go down I believe and I'm pulling down
the drive he's chasing me down the
driveway in his bathrobe mm-hmm young
man young man and he wants to give me
all his Faberge products cuz he was a
brand ambassador so for years I
cherished my soap on a rope from Cary
Grant in the shape of a microphone or as
I like to say I think it was the
microphone I think that's what the shape
was properly shaped for the way your
hair makes you look there's the next one
you're credited as a performer of proud
married and then in 1989 Academy Awards
is that true oh yeah that's it's it's
our nation's great shame what do you
mean my parents on the Academy Awards is
that right oh this is a man who needs to
spend some time on Google okay or need
to spend some time every year before the
Oscars they will bring me out as the
Oscar punching bag for most embarrassing
Oscar moment apparently as my duet was
with Snow White singing Proud Mary is
that what you know notwithstanding the
fact that two years ago they announced
the wrong best picture see it's me
thirty years on all right last one
during the filming of The Outsiders you
turned 18 and the other boys in the cast
pranked you by trashing your hotel room
by saran-wrapping the toilet and
spraying fire extinguishers into the
room said true story absolutely true it
was like that was my college experience
I was a turning 18 it would have been
the equivalent of going away from home
for the first time and that's my
fraternity those guys are my frat
brothers what a shine today cross man
jeez look at that it's a good group look
how tough Tom Cruise is trying to look
in that photo
dude Tom Cruise was such a baller he was
he was he was probably might one of my
closest friend and he was so great
I was looked up to him and he was had
these cool things he would come up with
and I remember he was the first guy that
ever came up with this conceit of
tightening the titles of the movies he
was in to make him sound badass like he
did this you know the football movie all
the right moves yeah but yeah man when I
was making moves but then you know it
was a problem when he be like yeah when
I was making cocktail there's kind of
you know now I like to [ __ ] yeah when I
was in tail doesn't tail can't do it
either way you go like when Marty
scheana and I were doing West you know
on the set of boy boy in Oxford blue
sets up or just blues see it's important
to choose if you choose the wrong one
it's not as good there's always one
that's cooler there like which is like
like when I was doing recreation yeah
doesn't it but if I'm doing parks right
instead of projects you into the park
yeah man amy poehler and ina parks we
laughed all the time and perks the set
of Wayne is just you know you wouldn't
talk about Tom Cruise - this was the
fact that blew our minds when the last
Mission Impossible came out and he was
running all over like a broken broken
ankle that is just amazing whatever is
that he was he is right now the age in
these movies doing this that Wilford
Brimley was during cocoon that's a fact
that is that's boom like mind-blowing
that's it's mind-blowing
it's what makes it mind-blowing is that
Tom Cruise is doing that at that age or
Wilford Brimley was really that young in
cocoon I did a movie Wilford Brimley he
was the first great character actor I
ever worked with it was a movie called
Hotel New Hampshire what are we doing on
that one so when you do Hampshire
Hampshire when you did hotel about just
rising new when you did new right doing
new
ham when I was working on new with
Brimley brigly was that he was the first
actor I ever met who only read his part
of the script
what do you mean like so he he died
halfway through the movie not actually
in real life as he had no idea what the
movie was about right didn't read it
after his character died so he would
just drop he just waited like what do
they call it we're driving seven days
what do they call you in this movie and
I was like well they call me John oh
good well then that's what I'll call you
John I was like he hadn't read it it's
clear nobody talks about what's the
right thing to do to I mean that's what
he talks about with the oats it's the
right thing and I being the greatest
sports movie of all time the natural I'm
a butcher's guy I maybe oh I'm
negotiating it was this yes to do the
movie with David on Spock who directed
Hoosiers and Rudi's you play Carol
Rosenblum and it's the story of the 1958
championship and the creation of the
modern NFL let's do call it a season
it's great so we're trying to put this
movie together and it's gonna be if we
can pull it off it's gonna be awesome
fantastic yeah this is great stuff man
yeah I love when you come on wrong we
have fun we could talk about anything
you know right mental samurai on Fox
Tuesdays at 9:00 Eastern Time it is a
wild show visually intelligent and it's
all sorts of good stuff you can watch it
Tuesday nights
9:00 Eastern on Fox at Rob Lowe on
Twitter at Rob Lowe official on
Instagram good to see you bro good to
see them so fun that's let's uh wrap up
this show and get you set for our New
York shows where we're headed to after
this one the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience